hello or glad you've joined us for our
first of six 2017 sync d3 webinars
today's presentations will be on the
topic of disease models with talks on
using IKEA C's in genome engineering to
build disease models in 3d cell culture
developing better in vitro cell models
for drug discovery
Landry O'Rourke of lab roots and I'll be
moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
it's brought to you by thermo Fisher
Scientific thermo Fisher is a world
leader and serving science mission is to
enable customers to make the world
healthier cleaner and safer
Thermo Fisher Scientific helps their
customers accelerate life sciences
research solve complex analytical
challenges improve patient diagnostics
and increase laboratory productivity for
more information please visit
www.gfi.com/webmonitor the Q&A box which
will open when you click the green to an
A button at the lower left of the
presentation window questions will be
answered after the presentation to
enlarge the slide window click on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problems by clicking on the
green Q&A button at lower left I now
present today's speakers David Piper PhD
are in the director for D cell biology
and synthetic biology businesses at
Thermo Fisher Scientific mark Kennedy
PhD and RD scientist at the thermo
Fisher Scientific cell biology ed me
talks group dr. Piper has led teams at
Thermo Fisher Scientific for over ten
years in the development of products and
services for cellular engineering
biochemical assays and cell based assays
to the screening of multiple
target classes and next-generation
solution for drug discovery using IPS II
based approaches these efforts are
directed at generating more
pathophysiological irrelevant cell
models through the use of reprogramming
stem cell culture characterization and
differentiation genomic engineering and
assay development in male lead schemes
that provide molecular biology and
cellular biology services including cDNA
library synthesis Hydra put cloning
CRISPR and 2 on design and generation
lentivirus generation Batman virus
generation cell engineering active
development lengthy array CRISPR
libraries and functional genomics
screening as a Cancer Research training
award postdoctoral fellow in a
laboratory of Terry T Yamaguchi at the
National Cancer Institute dr. Kennedy
study gene regulatory network controlled
by which signaling and models of
mammalian
embryogenesis he has published many
peer-reviewed research articles and
leading journals such as PNAS and
development at Thermo Fisher Scientific
dr. Kennedy is part of a team that
focuses on the development of new in
vitro 3d cell culture models his ongoing
work focuses on the utilization of human
embryonic stem cells iPS ES and primary
cells and their application in steroids
organoids and Co culture systems the
speakers complete bios are found on the
lab route website dr. Piper will now
begin his presentation thank you very
much for the kind introduction and just
like to greet all of our participants
and say thank you for joining us this
morning this afternoon or this evening
depending on where you may be and
allowing us to share some of our recent
advancements in the realm of IPSC
derived disease models to start with I
just kind of want to ground everyone I
think the approach and the idea here is
relatively straightforward and as a
thought that people have had really
probably since the advent of the
isolation of human embryonic stem cells
in 1998 by Jamie Thompson in his
laboratory and later
particularly in 2006 the advent of
induced pluripotent stem cells by the
advancements of Shinya Yamanaka and
again Jamie Thompson and their groups
and what we'd like to try to understand
is how human biology works there are a
number of inputs that we have that are
variables or genetics our environment
our nutrition various drugs that we may
use to treat disease or that people may
use in recreational ways that impact a
number of outputs that we can elucidate
as symptoms so that we feel as humans
and can point to as well as biomarkers
that may be measured through
instrumentation and of course a number
of outcomes that may occur in terms of
loss of mobility or function or even of
course loss of life what we'd like to do
is try to understand that with a
relatively straightforward model and our
discovery processes where we would build
a model to predict these outputs and
translate them to the organisms and we
start with cells that we have again a
number of inputs that we might control
to mimic these variables through the
over expression of genes or the
knockdown or knockout of genes by
changing the media systems that the
cells are in whether that be the media
itself or the supplementation or the co
culture or the three-dimensional nature
that will mark mark we'll talk about
later as well as of course treating them
with various compounds that might be
used as therapeutics and we can measure
the outputs of those cells in terms of
gene expression protein function various
aspects of cell health and many other
cell phenotypes that are relevant to the
path of physiological state of the cell
and ultimately translate that back to
the human being and again those symptoms
and biomarkers as I said in in 2006
following the advent of induced
pluripotent stem cell reprogramming
techniques advanced by Shinya Amnon
Yamanaka and Jamie Thompson's labs
it became relatively quickly clear to
people that we could use these cells
shown on the top left that are
pluripotent and become can become any
cell type in the body essentially and
can be kept in culture for many many
divisions we can take these from
patients that have no clinical disease
phenotype or genotype or we could take
them from folks that are displaying
specific disease phenotypes and
genotypes and using those patient
samples we can reprogram skin or blood
to create these IPS CS and then further
address the genomic nature of that
sample to either take a wild-type cell
and insert a mutation or take a diseased
sample and revert a mutation and thereby
create an isogenic pair shown on the
bottom left in the sort of pink tan
color and then these two isogenic paired
cells can be differentiated into a cell
type of interest shown here neurons for
instance to study diseases such as
Parkinson's disease and phenotypic
comparisons can be made using a variety
of cell based assays and indicators that
may allow us to quantitate cellular
function that is specifically relevant
to that disease in that cell type that
is again specifically relevant to the
tissue type that's affected in the human
body and we have over the years over the
past five to seven years really
generated an entire portfolio of
products to help support that effort
beginning with the patient where we have
media systems that allow you to culture
those blood cells or those fibroblasts
and we have genetic instrumentation like
our Ion Torrent PGM or proton or s5 to
characterize the genetic the genotype of
those patients we have a number of ways
to reprogram those cells perhaps the
most efficient of which is our site
attuned sendai virus and I'll touch on
on that momentarily in a little bit
or detail we've developed culture
systems are essential 8 being a very
standard system that was developed by
Jamie Thompson's lab and has been used
very widely to culture and expand cells
and we have a number of ways to
characterize those I pscs antibodies for
specific proteins that we know to be
expressed by pluripotent stem cells or
their progeny as well as a very
comprehensive gene panel that we call
the PSC tech ma'am human scorecard to
understand the gene expression of IPS CS
as well as their progeny we have
developed a number of engineering
systems based on technology associated
with both talons and the CRISPR cast 9
systems and I'll go into a little more
detail about both of those as that is
really the crux of this talk and then
we've developed some media systems that
allow for the induction or
differentiation of IPS CS to a number of
downstream progeny and that has we've
been coupling those with our measurement
systems from both our high-throughput
screening teams and our high content
imaging teams and our molecular probes
franchises to help develop systems that
allow us to measure function from those
cells that again can be equated back to
the human biology that we're interested
in a few years ago we embarked on a
collaboration with the Parkinson's
Institute and I'm just showing that here
quickly and this sort of references back
to that workflow so you can see the
colored boxes that I sort of went
through before in terms of getting
patient samples from donors that had
known clinical parkinsonian symptoms and
genotypes we took those fibroblasts we
cultured them in our media systems we
reprogram them with our site attunes
antivirus to make IPS CS which were
again characterized with various tools
these were then edited at the time using
our talent based gene editing
specifically modified the disease
relevant genes and revert them to
wild-type and then we used our neural
induction media to create neural stem
cells and further those cells were used
to differentiate into dopaminergic
neurons and glia and we looked at a
number of functional assays in these
various progeny to look for phenotypes
that varied in the wild-type versus the
disease samples on the left are a number
of patient donor samples that indicate
various disease mutations or spontaneous
mutations as well as controls we looked
at a number of different cell lines and
you know for the most part this this
workflow is very predictable and was
relatively straightforward to accomplish
when we look at reprogram a
reprogramming efficiency here we tested
a number of densities and using the
various samples that are indicated here
and as shown on the previous slide I
believe the age groups were quite varied
as well but irrespective of the age of
the donor or the specific disease
associated with the donor which do tend
to impact our ability to reprogram we
were able to get efficiencies anywhere
from point zero one percent to point
three percent and these numbers have
have improved considerably over the past
few years as well but these these
efficiencies were plenty to allow us to
choose multiple clones from each sample
and move those clones forward for
further expansion and characterization
and again that characterization was
generally carried out using a series of
antibodies for known pluripotent
proteins for for example we also looked
at extracellular surface proteins that
are correlated with ploy potency like
trial 1 - 81 trial 1 - 60 and we looked
at these on our Floyd imaging stations
as well as quantitated them using our
tune
to focusing cytometer and you can see on
the bottom that we have about 88% of the
cells they're being stained with Nanog
and SSC a4 indicating that we have a
highly pluripotent culture of great
homogeneity in these in this particular
IPS see sample from donor PD 3 we also
characterized the gene expression of
those IPS CS using our CAC ma'am
HP SC score card which we developed as a
collaboration with dr. Alex Meissner at
Harvard based on one of his landmark
publications where he looked at hundreds
of genes and the genomic and epigenomic
signature of es CS and IPS CS to
understand how how they overlap and how
close those two types of pluripotent
stem cells are in terms of their gene
expression patterns and from that we are
able to work with him to reduce that
content to a smaller set of key
predictive markers on the order of 90
genes that we could put in a single
plate that would allow us and our
customers to rapidly evaluate the
pluripotent nature of the IPS see itself
as well as embryo eight bodies derived
from that IPS see and either look at all
the specific genes if desired or get
sort of a thumbs-up thumbs-down based on
those gene panels as they relate to a
database of about 13 well characterized
IPS CS that set the standard for that
gene expression panel so you can see
here we have a couple different IPS CS
on the left one that came from donor
that had multiple systems atrophy and a
spontaneous presentation of Parkinson's
and then on the right patient that was a
control that had no clinical phenotype
and the sort of yellow single dots shows
you that when we look at those IPS CS in
that 90 gene panel overall those cells
expressed
potin markers as expected one compared
again to that benchmark of 13 IPS CS and
then when we generated embroider a non
directed differentiation by removing fgf
and allowing the cells to form EBS and
suspension we then looked at those
samples and we saw up regulation of
genes that are typically expressed in
ectodermal endodermal and Mesa dermal
layers and a down regulation of the
pluripotent genes again as expected
now the reprogramming the
characterization again relatively
straightforward we had no problems
moving those pieces forward and and they
really behaved as expected and we think
that in terms of generating cells from
patients that is not really a hurdle for
us today however there are have been
significant challenges in our ability to
edit these cells and we know many have
been barked on these these tasks and
certainly there are no there's no longer
table K shion's in the area we've seen
many many different examples but I think
what is not always appreciated in the
publication's is the amount of time and
labor and TDM associated with some of
these manipulations so to begin with low
cleavage and low homology directed
repair combination efficiencies which we
often see when delivering tools to IP
SCS require that we generate many clones
to find the reversion or the
introduction of the disease mutation in
a homozygous single-cell clone once
we've put those tools into a pool of
cells the cells need to be singular eyes
and they need to be singular eyes for
the transfection they also need to be
synced kept singular post transaction to
allow us to plate cells at a very low
density to form well separated colonies
it's relatively well known in the field
that stems
do not like being alone this puts a lot
of stress on them it can often cause
cell death it can cause abnormalities in
the karyotype of the cells where you may
select for cells that create
duplications of chromosomes or portions
of chromosomes that may give them growth
advantages so it can be a real challenge
in addition the cells can be somewhat
motile so even though you've created
well separated colonies in many cases
the colonies do not wind up being
homogeneous in these situations where we
plate the cells at these limited
delusions it does require the manual
isolation of those colonies and we
really want to take half of that colony
and use it for expansion and another
half for screening so that we can get
rid of the cells that aren't what we
want and reduce the amount of colonies
that we're keeping in culture and then
finally again once we identify colonies
that have what we want
oftentimes we need to replate them
because they're not necessarily a
homogeneous clone and we may need to
dilute them down again in order to
achieve that so if I take that stem cell
workflow I showed you and break it down
into the pieces that are more germane to
the disease model construction and
engineering piece we think about
delivery and engineering and again what
we've used previously are our gene art
precision towels and we have cloned and
expand those cells in essential 8 medium
using limited plating dilution
strategies and we have screened those
typically using either tack mam allele
specific competitive SNP assays or Ion
Torrent sequencing we during those
projects use our neural induction media
to generate neural stem cells and then
downstream neurons from that point and
as mentioned had focused principally on
self health assays so what have we done
lately in terms of delivery oh that let
me point out again as mentioned
the key piece for tedium here is this
circle between clone expand and screen
expand and as I said a key roadblock
here was the inability to get single
cells and create homogeneous colonies
off the first round to allow for the
type of more rigorous screening and
predictable outcomes that we get from
cells that tend to be easily take
delivery easily and and withstand
sorting easily so what have we done
lately when it comes to delivery and
engineering we've made significant
improvements to our gene our CRISPR cast
9 system and some of these are available
already as an early access we have a new
version of our cast 9 nucleus protein
that can be used with guide RNAs to
create a ribonucleoprotein complex that
can be delivered directly to cells to
drive high editing efficiency we also
have our perfect matched house and these
are talents that do not require have the
5 prime t requirement so these can be
addressed to any location in the human
genome and a point that I will make
there is it's becoming more and more
clear that homology directed repair
[Music]
pieces of DNA and creating cut sides
creating double-stranded breaks very
close to the single nuclei nucleotide
polymorphism that you would like to
change or introduce so in many cases we
may not have a CRISPR that guide RNA
that can address a specific site due to
the pam requirement on the three prime
end of that CRISPR cast 9 so if you find
yourself working with mutations where a
CRISPR guide RNA will not cut within a
small stretch say 10 base pairs of the
SNP you may want to consider using a
perfect match tail as that will really
dramatically increase your HDR
efficiencies and then finally we've also
created a stable cast 9i PSC which I'll
talk about today where
the cast 9 nucleus is expressed in the
IPSC and we can very easily and
effectively deliver guide RNAs to
achieve high cleavage efficiencies and
high HDR efficiencies we've made some
very significant improvements to our
media systems and have launched this
year a stem flex medium that has been
key to the recovery following
electroporation or lipid introduction of
guide RNAs as well as allowed us to
support single-cell IPSC sorting which
I'll talk about today that same media
has allowed us to expand those clones
effectively and once we've identified
them to bulk them up to a large size
where we can go ahead and then
characterize and differentiate them into
a number of cell types and now in
addition to neural stem cells our media
teams have developed directed monolayer
differentiation kits that allow us to
generate cardiomyocytes midbrain
dopaminergic neurons as well as cortical
neurons and glia and finally we're using
those cells in measurement systems in
both our high content imaging platforms
using our cell insight cx-5 and our
molecular probes reagents as well as
high-throughput cell based assays
including for example functional assays
that allow us to visualize and
quantitate things such as calcium flux
and release or plasma membrane voltage
or potassium flux that are important for
cells like cardiomyocytes and neurons in
their excitation contraction coupling or
their exit rate excitation secretion so
what I'll focus on here first are our
improvements around delivery and
engineering and as I mentioned for the
purposes of this talk I will focus on
the caste 9 IPS see but please realize
that we have significant significant
improvements in efficiency
again with our new Cassadine protein as
well as the use of our perfect match
towels to address snps that may not be
near a guide RNA pattern so what is our
cast nine IPSC and how did we generate
it
we took our give Co IPSC episomal line
that is available in our catalogue a
well-characterized IPSC can be used to
generate many downstream progeny and
using a lentiviral construct that is
part of our Lenti array CRISPR library
platforms we have a lentivirus that
encodes a caste 9 nucleus and includes a
Blastoise Eden resistance cassette we
introduced that lentiviral construct to
our human episome --all IPSC caste 9
line we selected with Blastoise Eden and
chose colonies that we characterized and
I'll go through the characterization of
some of those that ultimately led to us
choosing the county that had the best
looking morphology growth and
characteristics that match the wild type
caste 9 line so post selection we
examine these colonies for their
morphology so you can hopefully see that
on the top left in the photo micrograph
and these cells look as expected similar
to the wild type caste nine in our
feeder free essential 8 media systems we
ran a karyotype standard karyotype
analysis on those cells shown in the top
middle panel and there was no change in
karyotype from the Lenti delivery in the
caste 9 expressing IPS CS as compared to
wild-type we looked at pluripotency
markers using anti trial 1 - 60 antibody
and we ran the TAC mam h PSC scorecard
shown on the bottom left and you can see
that the give Co IPS see shown in back
black dots and the caste 9 human IPS see
shown in red dots are nearly identical
for their expression of self-renewal
markers
as well as active derbies a German
endoderm and these line up very well
with our expectations compared to the
benchmark of the 13 IPSC and yes either
used in our database so in summary our
cast nine IPSC retain normal morphology
normal karyotype and had a pluripotency
similar to our parental line as measured
by gene expression next we
differentiated those cells in a non
directed weight again removing fgf and
forming embroid bodies and we examined
the gene expression of those embryo IDs
using the tech man's scorecard and on
top you'll see that the EBS on day 7 and
21 shown in the middle and the bottom
row at a market decrease in the
self-renewal markers with an increasing
increase in expression of the ectodermal
visa dermal and endodermal markers again
as expected and some of these markers we
also examined using a Mita site of
chemistry so on the bottom left you can
see staining of the nuclei with Daffy
and beta 3 tubulin common ectodermal
marker shown in red and on the bottom
right panel again you'll see dabby
staining the nuclei in blue and staining
of smooth muscle actin as an visa dermal
mark so this showed us that the cast 9i
PSC can differentiate through EBS to all
three germ layers as evidenced by both
genetic and protein expression analysis
we further tested those cast 9 IPS CS to
understand if they could be directed
towards specific progeny through our
mono layer differentiations using our
kits and here you can see a fluorescent
micrographs of cardiomyocytes at 10x +
20 X where we've stained the nuclei in
blue with our new blue reagent and used
anti cardiac troponin shown in green
with an alexa fluor 48 label to
demonstrate evidence of cardiac protein
expression
we also use these cells to generate
floorplate progenitors which are an
intermediate to our midbrain floorplate
derived dopaminergic neurons and here
you'll see on the left are cast nine
IPSC derived dopaminergic neuron
progenitors and on the right the
wild-type give Co IPSC derived
dopaminergic progenitor z' and you'll
see staining or are expected markers box
a 2m x 1 and OT x 2 and a down
regulation of socks 1 and essentially
our staining for both the give Co IPS
see in the cast on IPS see look
equivalent suggesting that the Cassadine
IPS see can efficiently make midbrain
floorplate progenitors those cells were
used to further generate our
dopaminergic neurons and here on top
you'll see the wild-type IPS CS and on
the bottom the cast 9 IPS sees that were
used to generate these neurons and
staining for tyrosine hydroxylase a key
enzyme in the biosynthetic pathway for
dopamine as well as beta 3 tubulin a key
neuroectodermal marker and merge
staining of those markers and the nuclei
shown in blue on the far right so again
we see immuno Saito chemical evidence
that our cast 9i PSC can be efficiently
differentiated into dopaminergic neurons
now the final question was can we use
these cells to create double-stranded
breaks and introduce single nucleotide
polymorphisms and here instead of
reverting a patient sample we were
asking the question can we use this
unified chassis to create a set of
protocols for many different snps that
may underlie different diseases and
generate a system that would allow
people to model monogenic diseases that
are necessary and sufficient to drive
the phenotypes that one
would expect to see in these cells so on
the top left you see a bar graph for
guide RNAs that were directed against
cardiac troponin in the first two sets
of bar graphs against hprt in the third
set and against beta 2 microglobulin in
the far right and we are looking here at
the cleavage efficiency which again is
generated from our genomic cleavage
detection kit where you create a PCR
fragment across the site where the in
del or the SNP is and if you've made a
change hetero duplexes form in that in
those PCR products and those hetero
duplexes can be cut by an endonuclease
which will create a specific gel banding
pattern which you can see on the bottom
left where the first row under b2m grna
or the first row under hprt indicate no
editing and the other bands show the
cleavage efficiency you can see the
smaller bands that result from the
endonuclease activity when we add
increasing amounts of guide RNA from 0
to 50 to 100 to 200 to 400 nanograms and
these were delivered using our neon
transparency lect wroclaw rated into the
IPS cs and they were recovered in stem
flex media again and quantitative by the
gcd assay so that allowed us to get very
high in del percentages as shown by the
table on the right in the middle column
for a number of genes and a number of
different guide RNAs tested for each of
those genes we had in del frequencies
that ranged anywhere from 23 to as high
as 78% now additionally we included
small DNA Legos to revert or to
introduce the snps associated with these
diseases and in order to assess the HDR
efficiency we ran next-gen sequencing
across those snps and looked at the
percentage of reads that had either the
wild-type nuclei
or the desire disease relevant
nucleotide and you can see those
percentages on the far right and we saw
anywhere from 7 to 37% HDR which is
really a significant uptick compared to
what we had seen previously when we had
first one our editing workflow and our
patient derived samples using DNA based
plasmids for our talents so we are very
excited about this now another question
we had was is there sustained expression
of caste 9 as we differentiate those
cells and this is showing you that as we
generate floorplate progenitors to
create dopaminergic neurons we can
clearly visualize caste 9 on a Western
blot and that gave us some thoughts
about how we may be able to leverage
these cells later from both the
wild-type and the disease isogenic pairs
so we could see clear Cassadine
expression and the floorplate
progenitors and furthermore we could
show that we could actually edit in
those caste 9 IPS see derived
progenitors and here you see again our
genomic cleavage assays for hprt
lark to alpha synuclein and two
different low Seifer lar 2 and again
looking at 0 50 100 200 and 400
nanograms of guide RNA introduced to
these progenitor cells and we're getting
as high as 60% cleavage based on that
genomic cleavage as say using life
effect amine based delivery of those
guides so using our RNA i max to deliver
in vitro transcribed guide RNAs so that
also has given us a lot of thought about
how we can use these models later
downstream to do potentially knockout
studies so the next piece I want to talk
about is how we have made some
improvements
in our media systems that have supported
the generation of clones following the
introduction of these genome editing
tools so it's all well and good that
we've improved the editing efficiency
from the standpoint of cleavage as well
as homology directed repair system we've
been able to show that we can get
phenomenal recovery post electroporation
of the system we can sequence those
pools and understand very effectively
what our efficiency is which can inform
us as to how many single cells we might
need to sort and this media as I will
show you has begun to support those
activities directly so the team here in
Carlsbad in collaboration with our media
development teams and Fredrik have taken
that stem flex media and developed a
very stringent sorting protocol to
isolate single and viable pluripotent
stem cells so one of the first steps is
to simply create a set of very stringent
gates using both forward and side
scatter to exclude not just cell debris
but to be very clear and stringent
around excluding multiple any potential
multiple cell clumps we've also used
propidium iodide to exclude dying cells
and we've used anti trial 1 - 60 to
prioritize our gates around pluripotent
cells so we're quite confident that we
are pulling out single viable
pluripotent cells through this sorting
exercise we drop these cells into our
stem flex media and I'm showing you here
a comparison of that media with some of
the commonly used media systems that
come from both us and other vendors and
on the left you see the percent clone
formation
from cells dropped into media systems
without revita cell which is a
supplementation that we use and that
includes a very specific Rock inhibitor
and other supportive supplements when we
use simply the media systems using stem
flex we're able to get almost a 30%
recovery of single cells and if we clone
three or five we get even higher levels
and when you do clone three or five in
many cases the large bulk of those cells
actually do die and those systems me and
those numbers can support the generation
of single cells but frankly with a 30%
recovery of single cells we're doing
just fine and we're happy to sort more
plates to know that we do in fact have a
very clear and homogeneous culture now
shown on the right is an improvement in
those recovering efficiencies in all of
the media systems we tested when we
include revita cell and I should also
point out that we're dropping these
single cells onto a laminin 521
substrate so we offer all of those
systems in our catalog our stem flex
media our revised cell supplement on our
laminate five to one substrate and this
has really been a game changer for us in
order to generate effectively and
predictably single cell homogeneous
clones now on the next slide I had a
couple movies and I'm afraid that we
won't be able to share them with you but
what we did do was we kept a constant
monitor of these single cells over time
and in the wells we're clones arose we
were able to line back that video and
examine the entire well and prove to
ourselves physically and microscopically
that the clone was in fact derived from
a single cell and of course this can
also be verified through next-generation
sequencing by doing thousands of reads
at a specific location
and identifying that you have you know
ninety-eight percent or higher reads
that have the mutation or the wild-type
or fifty fifty as the case may be and
and statistically that quantitation
gives us a great level of confidence
that we have clones that came from a
single genotype so the next piece then
was again how do we screen and expand
these cells and here again the stem flex
media has been critical to our ability
to take those single cells and get them
to a level where we can easily sequence
them all and then further expand the
winners and what I'm showing you here
are the pools which we had again
generated through electroporation and
sequenced using next-gen sequencing to
understand HDR efficiencies which I
showed you before those were somewhere
between again seven and forty percent
roughly and here what I'm showing you
are the sequencing results from all of
the clones that we generated from those
pools so for instance in this first pie
chart we had a lark to g20 19's
introduction and when we had done the
NGS on the pool we saw that 26% of our
reads indicated we had a g20 19's
mutation and here what you see in the
pie chart is when we looked at the
clones 88% of the clones had an in Dell
whereas about 4% of them we're
homozygous wild-type and eight percent
of them were homozygous snps
interestingly in this particular
population we did not observe any
heterozygotes in the middle you see
another pie chart for alert to eye 2020
here we had about 14 percent of the
reads in our pool that indicated we had
that mutation and here we see about 58
Center the cells within Dells 38% with
wild-type homozygous wild-type and about
2% homozygous snip or 2% heterozygous
snip for alpha synuclein a 30 P we had
about 34% HDR and when we examined all
of the single clones that we sorted we
had actually 48% of them with double
homozygous knockouts or homozygous snips
excuse me with cardiac troponin T we had
about 11% HDR in the pool about 2%
homozygous snips about 36% while I have
been about 62% in Dells and with nav 1.5
E
10:53 K we had about 41% HDR in the pool
and about 30% homozygous snips about 6%
heterozygous 39 percent in Dell 26%
homozygote wild-type so what I think you
can appreciate here is that what we get
out you know it's certainly possible if
we were to look at thousands of these
cells that the phenotypes are the
genotypes that arise might be more
stochastically representative of what we
see in the pool but it's more likely
that some of these numbers are biased
due to aspects of recombination that
perhaps we don't fully understand micro
homology allelic switches etc etc I mean
it's certainly curious to us that in
some cases we really don't see the
heterozygous and we expect that there
are some mechanisms that are underlying
that that we don't fully understand
today but the great news is that single
cell clones derived using stem flex and
lamina five to one allowed us in all of
these five examples to identify
homozygous edited clones following our
first sort so our next piece then was to
look at differentiation and measuring
and as I mentioned again we've generated
a number of new media and I'm going to
just touch briefly on what we've done
using
cardiomyocyte differentiation media what
we're trying to do is to use this cast
nine IPSC we'd like to introduce
mutations that are associated with each
of these cell types and demonstrate that
again we can introduce monogenic snps
that have a dominant genotypic effect
that will support cellular phenotypes
that are reflective of the disease so
with the cardiomyocytes i'll show you
some of the so based assays that the
team has developed using our wild-type
cast nine and now that we've generated
these mutants we'll be looking forward
to running these assays on the isogenic
pairs and i hope to share that type of
data with you in the future so using our
cardiac differentiation kit and our
Gimpo IPS CS we carried out the
differentiation procedure in six and
twelve well dishes and then replated
those cells into a 384-well dish for our
assays and for our assays we examined
the use of flow for our calcium
indicator and flow volt a dye that we
have based on nano wire technology that
allows us to measure the plasma membrane
potential and we imaged and quantitated
these on a Hama Matsu FD SS 6000 and on
the bottom left you can see what some of
those raw traces look like and these
indicate various beat rates and the
wells based on the various compounds
that we've put in the plate and in the
middle you can see how we characterize
sort of the baseline of that beat rate
with the Green Line and the peak with
the little red pluses and we can use
that to establish a frequency between
the peaks and amplitude from the
baseline to the top etc and by
quantitating those features we can plot
that against the concentration of the
compounds and understand some aspects of
their effects so in the next slide here
I'll tell you a little bit about how we
did that we loaded the cardiomyocytes
using our flow for direct reagent which
is a no wash reagent so it's very easy
to add it simply to the cells and carry
out your read you let that incubate for
about thirty minutes in this case we did
in fact change the media but typically
it's not necessary because that we do
have a quencher there and that should
allow you to simply add and read we
collect data before during and after
compound treatment the hama Matsu FD SS
has a liquid injection capability we ran
these compounds titrated as 10-point
curves with four replicates per
concentration and we use that to
generate concentration response curves
from post treatment data again
normalized to the pretreatment data and
of course we also ran DMS DMSO controls
that were our negatives so here you see
what a set of control cells look like
and again i apologize that we don't have
the video here but on the top left you
would be able to see clear fluorescent
intensity changes that represent the
calcium fluctuations that occur both due
to voltage-gated calcium channels and
the influx of calcium into the
cardiomyocytes as well as calcium
induced calcium release from internal
stores that is associated with that
excitation contraction coupling and on
the right you can see those fluctuations
in fluorescence intensity from that well
that indicate the essentially the beat
rate of those control cells then when we
add isoproterenol a known beta
adrenergic agonist that increases beat
rate through gpcr signaling and
modification of ion channels we can see
an increase in that B rate whereas when
we use for wrap amil a known calcium
channel blocker we can completely
obliterate that calcium signal as we
expect so we went ahead and took those
first sa feasibility results and we move
forward and ran a number of times three
different runs using high purity
cardiomyocytes for all the runs
we do see some loss of cells about 4 to
6 percent of the wells did not give us
detectable signals some issues around
either cell loading or cell health and
we will continue to optimize around that
but again using 4 replicates we were
able to get the data that we needed we
tested about 9 different compounds that
have very known very classic known
mechanisms of action at a number of
cardiac ion channels and gpcrs as shown
in the middle panel here and those
compounds based on those mechanism
mechanisms of action also have a very
clear and no effect on the calcium
transients so those results are shown
here where we have the drug effect on
the cardio myocyte beat rate shown on
the top row as well as the amplitude
shown in the middle row and the duration
of those Peaks shown on the bottom row
and again verapamil you can see with
increasing concentrations obliterates
the beat rate and the amplitude and the
duration because it's a known calcium
channel blocker as is bakei whereas
isoproterenol unknown beta adrenergic
agonist that increases betrayed through
modulation of ion channels increases
beat rate as you increase concentration
as well as the amplitude however it
decreases beat duration consistent with
our expectations and on the far right
efore t31 a known blocker of the delayed
rectifier or commonly called human ether
or a go-go related gene her potassium
channel responsible for repolarization
of the cardiac action potential and
often involved in acquired long QT
syndrome or drug-induced long QT
syndrome ie 40:31 has a noticeable
decrease on the beat rate due to its
effect on that potassium channel as well
as changes to the beat amplitude and
beat duration so this all lined up very
well with our expectations in wild-type
IPS ES and cardiomyocytes and again we
look forward to moving those studies
forward
with some of the mutations that we've
introduced as I mentioned we'd like to
generate a number of isogenic clones in
this cast 9 IPS see using our stem flex
media systems to model hypertrophy with
mutations in cardiac troponin or Brugada
syndrome with mutations in nab 1.5 or l
QT syndrome by introducing mutations in
k CH 2 or the herb channel for
parkinson's disease we've introduced a
number of mutations in alpha synuclein
and alar 2 that should derive specific
phenotypes that we expect and we have
begun differentiating these two relevant
cell types again using our cardio
myocyte differentiation kit or our
dopaminergic neuron differentiation kit
and we're seeing the expected staining
of cardiac or dopaminergic neurons and
finally we'll be using those cell types
to develop functional assays and
quantitate cellular phenotypes using
some of our cell health reagents like
presto blue to measure cell metabolism
or psyche want direct to measure DNA
content and proliferation or click it
edu to measure incorporation of
nucleotides and proliferation we'll be
looking at excitability through calcium
flux with flow for potassium flux with
flux or and membrane potential with blue
volt and we'll be examining a number of
parameters using high content imaging to
include but not be limited to cell size
cell health neurite outgrowth
mitochondrial health Lewy bodies protein
aggregation etc and again look forward
to sharing some of that data with you in
the future so we took a system that a
few years ago was developed using
patient derived or donor derived samples
where we had reprogrammed them into IPS
ES and used gene are precision towels
and sorted cells using limited dilution
plating that created a very laborious
cycle until we are able to get
homogeneous clones and that cycle was
not very pretty
acta bull and it was quite painful for
the bench scientists we generated neural
stem cells and using those neural stem
cells and their downstream neurons and
glia looked at a variety of cell health
assays today we've made improvements in
all of these areas and generated really
a very direct workflow to get from a
stem cell to edited clones that are
derived from single cells where we can
really essentially first time right find
double s homozygous SNP either
reversions or insertions and we can use
those isogenic pairs to generate a
number of different cell types including
cardiomyocytes dopaminergic neurons and
cortical neurons and glia and ER begin
using beginning to use a wide variety of
our measurement tools to quantitate
these cellular phenotypes so in summary
our stable caste nine IPS see exhibited
all the expected properties of the
wild-type IPS see and was able to
support high efficiency cleavage and HDR
and allows for the cleavage of genes in
differentiated progeny our improved
sorting protocols were supported by our
stem flex media and that gating of the
in those protocols supports the
isolation of healthy and pluripotent IPS
CS the stem flex media in combination
with laminin 521 supports a very high
efficiency recovery following that sort
and allowed for the reliable and
predictive recovery and identification
of homozygous edited IPS CS our clone
identification and expansion was
dramatically reduced because the
combination of the high efficiency HDR
and the single cell sorting and recovery
support of the expansion of clones that
were homozygous and could be easily
identified by downstream sequencing our
differentiation and measurement we've
established proof of principle for our
wild-type cardiomyocytes and again look
forward to looking at these isogenic
pairs
the next few months so we really see a
significant reduction in effort in cycle
times this is our goal to really remove
the need for manual clone isolation and
repeated sub cloning and reduce
timelines by months to support the first
time right production of isogenic pairs
so with that I again would like to thank
all of the participants for joining us
this morning afternoon and evening and
I'm happy to take any questions that
have arisen over the course of the
conversation
thank you dr. Piper for that informative
presentation I will now turn it over to
dr. Kennedy
okay hi my name is Mark first of all I
would like to thank everyone for tuning
in here today I'm an RD scientists in
the cell biology program our more
specifically within the add me toques
group at thermo scientific and the title
of my presentation today is going to be
3d cell culture developing better in
vitro cell models for drug discovery so
my goal of this short talk really is
just to give a fairly high-level
overview of several 3d cell culture
models primarily I'll talk about
spheroids and organoids and the promises
these systems offer and then I'll end
with a couple brief highlights from
published papers that demonstrate the
utility of these systems for disease
modeling and drug screening so I'm sure
everyone here is familiar with
traditional two-dimensional model air
cultures these systems typically consist
of growing a cell line of interest like
a cancer cell line by growing it
directly on 2d plastic surfaces or
sometimes on a two-dimensional surface
that's been pre coated with a substrate
to improve cell attachment and growth
however more and more researchers are
exploring the use of more complex and
advanced cell culture systems such as
three dimensional cell culture systems
in an attempt to create model systems
that better reflect how cells normally
grow and behave in intact
organisms in other words the ultimate
goal is to make in vitro cell models
that better reflect the complexity of
human physiology and so spirit and
organoids are two prominent examples of
3d systems that rely on selig regression
to make such 3d cell structures in
addition to these there are so called
the organ chips is another example of an
advanced cell culture system that shows
much promise and these technologies are
also very rapidly advancing
organs on chips for other people they're
often called micro physiological systems
and these are systems in which cells can
be grown sort of in 2d or 3d and may
also include things like extracellular
matrices and other physiological cues
such as shear flow and mechanical
stimuli these micro physiological
systems may also have the advantage of
being able to see really link multiple
organo tipic model systems to enable
researchers to study interactions
between oregon like systems so to
illustrate the rise in popularity of 3d
model systems this graph is more
specific about organize but but this
graph is meant to show the increase in
the number of publications from recent
years that utilize organoids and in part
this really underscores the reams of new
data that suggests how 3d models can
better approximate the invivo physiology
compared to traditional 2d models and
for me of course coming from a company
standpoint this observation is obviously
a main driver of our interest in 3d
model systems as we look for new ways to
better enable our customers to reach
their to meet their research needs and
to put this another way and some of the
reasons why organoids are really gaining
popularity is that these stem cell
derived models are probably the best
available models to study human
embryonic development in the past much
of what we've learned about human
development has come from studying a
variety of animal models that range from
frogs and fish to chickens and mice and
a whole bunch of others and also from
two-dimensional human stem cell culture
and as immensely valuable as these
systems have been and continue to be at
informing our understanding of human
development and this is still immense
and not everything we learn from these
animal models directly apply to humans
and this is particularly true of our
understanding of drug metabolism which
in turn has a significant impact on the
effectiveness of drug screening
campaigns as a result there is seems to
be a clear opening for new cell culture
models such as steroids and organelle
that has a potential to help us better
study and understand the mechanisms of
human disease and since these are stem
cell derived systems they can be coupled
with IPS CS or induced pluripotent stem
cells suggesting that they may also have
other applications as medical research
continues to march towards personalized
medicine and personalized toxicology so
with that sort of brief introduction I'd
like to move on to talk more
specifically about spheroid and
organized models and I think a good
place to start is with some definition
as these terms
steroids organoids and even tumour IDEs
seem to often get used somewhat
interchangeably and I don't think this
this is really correct and so for at
least for the purposes of this
presentation I want to make sure that
we're all on the same page when I refer
to either steroids or organoids in this
presentation so it's clear that you know
what I'm talking about
and so we've the spot we've defined
spheroids
as a 3d cellular aggregate composed of
one or more cell types that can grow and
proliferate and may exhibit enhance
physiological responses but do not
undergo proliferation or
self-organization in other words they
there isn't a stem cell compartment so
although you can aggregate these cells
and they may work together and improve
their physiological responses kind of
the cells you put in the system is what
you will have for the duration of your
experiment in contrast organoids can be
defined as a 3d structure derived
entirely from other PSCs
or neonatal tissue stem cells or adult
stem and progenitor cells in which cells
spontaneously self-organize into
properly differentiated functional cell
types and progenitors and which resemble
their in vivo counterparts and
recapitulate at least some function of
the organ and this is a definition that
we've been going with in his hair and
this is derived from from this reference
you can see here which is a very nice
review paper
organize and lastly I would like to
mention to muroids although I won't be
talking about these systems for the rest
of my presentation I do want to take
just a moment to head off any potential
confusion that might exist between
spheroids and to muroids just given that
sometimes I hear people talk about
spheroids and these because they're
derived from often from cancer cell
lines I think there's sometimes a
propensity to think of them as two
muroids when really a tumor Royd is is a
3d cellular aggregate that's derived
directly from the primary tumor tissue
if you will and so it retains the
properties of the original tumor and it
can be propagated in vitro and it does
not have all the accumulated effects
that many cancer cell lines have after
being cultured in the lab in 2d fir for
many years so as I mentioned 3d models
have great potential to improve the drug
discovery process and so what I'm
showing here is kind of a generic slide
that many of you have seen some version
of before and so I'll try not to belabor
this slide too much so this schematic
represents the cost relationship and
drug discovery beginning with the
screening of libraries of compounds to
identify lead lead candidates and some
of these candidates will ultimately make
it into animal studies and clinical
trials so pharmaceutical companies often
screen thousands and thousands of
compounds to identify candidates that
may have some therapeutic potential and
these large screening campaigns are
typically performed using traditional 2d
model air cultures because they are very
useful at identifying highly toxic
compounds but in general they have very
poor predictive value however the
associated relative cost of these
systems are quite low and so they're
often used as workhorses in the early
stages of the drug discovery process but
as fewer fewer compounds proceeded
through the drug discovery process the
associated costs tend to increase nearly
exponentially and this is why you often
hear phrases such as fail early fail
cheaply so there seems to be a clear
need to improve this
process so that fewer poor candidates
make it out of the early stages of the
drug discovery process and of course
then this begs the question can 3d
models help improve this process and so
based on the evidence currently
available in the scientific scientific
literature and reports being presented
by researchers and pharma it's indeed
becoming clear that 3d models may be
more predictive than traditional models
and what I mean by this is that steroids
for example are independently being
shown to have different sensitivities to
toxic compounds and show better
productivity than 2d cultures and so as
a result steroids and organoids could
potentially fit somewhere in the middle
or in the earlier steps of the standard
drug discovery workflow and this could
be a great benefit in making sure fewer
but safer and and perhaps even more
efficacious drugs progress through the
drug discovery and development process
so this table that you're seeing here is
taken from a really nice review paper
the references there on the bottom right
and it summarizes some comparisons
between 2d and 3d cultures with respect
to several important cellular
characteristics now I'm not going to go
through all of the this table but I
would like to highlight just a couple of
these points so first of all are the two
points in the bottom of the table and
the first of which here is that I just
want to remind us that you know it's
been shown by multiple people now that
the gene and protein expression profiles
found in 3d cell cultures are often much
more similar to the gene and expression
gene and protein expression profiles
that are found in in vivo cell types as
compared to the gene and protein
signatures that are often reported in 2d
cultures and secondly that due to the
three-dimensional nature of spheroids
cells are often more resistant to drug
exposure and in some cases this leads to
them being better predictors of drug of
in vivo drug responses and this is in
contrast to 2d cultures where drugs
might often look extremely effective and
early in the process
but then sale later on and of course
this is associated with the addition of
very significant costs lastly it is the
fact that 3d structures are 3d cell
models in these models nutrients growth
factors and oxygen and drugs and such
are not able to penetrate all the way
through the spheroid core and so this
may be a negative for some people but it
may be a positive for other people for
example who might be looking to develop
new cancer models so with the last few
slides I've been trying to impress upon
you that the improvements and potential
advantages of using 3d models and so
next I'd like to take just a couple of
slides to show some actual preliminary
data that we've been working with in
house on steroids to study sort of
general cytotoxicity and so the image
that you see here is a 2d image of a 3d
spheroid that was formed from the
hepatic car sonoma cell line fg2 I want
to show you this image to highlight
several general feature spheroids
and I just want to mention that this is
not new information in fact this is our
version of what you can find in many
Polish papers and so the image that you
see here is a fluorescent image the blue
fluorescence is just a P it's meant to
identify cell nuclei and the green
fluorescence that you see in the middle
labels what's known as being the product
core and so then the product cord
typically forms in a spheroid when it
reaches somewhere around maybe 150 to
300 microns in diameter depending on the
cell type that you're using and this
occurs really as a result of a couple of
different things and similar to what I
mentioned on the previous slide and that
is there's an inability of oxygen and
nutrients and growth factors and other
important things for good cell health
that are in the cell culture media that
are just not able to diffuse all the way
through the the spheroid to the center
to the cells in the center
and similar to this then the cells in
the center are also producing carbon
dioxide and metabolic wastes and these
are unable to diffuse out of the core
and as a result you get this hypoxic and
necrotic Center that develops so other
general features of the spheroid are
something that might be known to some as
a quiescent zone this is a region of
cells within the spheroid that I tend to
think of forming almost like a mantle
underneath the eight or so layers and
and on top of the than the product core
and this region is full of viable cells
but they tend not to be very
proliferative and lastly the outer cells
of steroids is where most of the
proliferation is often observed and this
is and these are responsible for much of
the sky growth that that one would see
so although many in the audience are
probably aware of some of this but for
those who aren't I just want to mention
a couple of common ways in which one can
facilitate the formation of spheroids
from agreeable cell types in some
instances for example spheroids
can be cultured by starting with small
clumps of cells or even single cells
grown in suspension or maybe in shaking
cultures and this tends to be a crude
but it is an efficient way to promote
the formation of spheroids
or if you happen to be using stem cells
this is one way to make embroid bodies
however this method often results in a
wide range of sizes and sometimes you
get a bunch of different shapes of
spheroids and sometimes steroids
interact with each other and kind of
merge and so then you're dealing with
you know are we really talking about one
steroid and that sort of thing
and so this can really have some
unwanted downstream effects on your
experiment so although it does work and
it's certainly a very low-tech way of
doing it it does have its disadvantages
another method is the hanging drop
method which doesn't work very well but
it tends to be quite tedious and can
also be labor-intensive it basically
consists of pipetting a drop of culture
medium you
with a number a known number of cells on
the underside of tissue culture dish
lids and then you just invert them and
so you create a hanging drop and the
cells that you put into that Culture
Media just like gravity tend to fall to
the bottom of the drop if you will where
the cells can interact and form an
aggregate another really effective
method that I find it is the use of
ultra low attachment round bottom plates
such as the the Sphero plates that are
offered by nunc and so the round bottom
allows cells to aggregate in one
location at the bottom of the well
they're also ultra low attachment so
they're treated in a way to prevent
cells from attaching of course to
promote their interaction with each
other and this format also gives you
expert control over the size of the
spheroid that you're trying to form and
it also allows you to make sure you form
one spheroid per well and so again this
circumvent some of the problems with
certainly with the static suspension or
shaking cultures and for anyone who's
interested I just wanted to to point out
that there's a really nice application
note on the thermo Fisher comm website
called harnessing new dimensions in your
research coming around two-spirit
culture and you can find some more
information if you're interested there
on the Nook sphere of plates and and
also there some really interesting info
here on the history of asteroids and
cultures if that's something that might
interest you so the other thing that I
find these plate formats very useful for
when it comes to forming secure plates
is that they can in some capacity be
used to or it can be coupled with SCI
content analysis and screening platforms
such as the salome exceed 7 which is a 7
channel confocal eye content screening
instrument that's really good because it
allows one to multiplex multiple
fluorescent assays for peanuts of
excreting and you can use really
powerful software to perform a wide
range of different types of analysis to
really measure any discernible effect
that drug exposure might have
have cell health and so this example I'm
showing you here is an example of an
experiment where we formed hep G to
spheroids and expose them to a ten-point
twofolds dilution of four different
drugs and we evaluated these in four
replicates in addition to the two lanes
of controls that you can see make up the
two left columns where the other the
leftmost column were just untreated
steroids and the second column was just
made up our story where spheroids that
were treated with just the DMSO vehicle
control and then we treated the all
these spheroids with different compounds
and for 48 hours and then we stained
them with the HTS mitochondrial health
kit which simultaneously monitors seto
toxicity and meadows access today and so
just to explain this a little more a
healthy spheroid such as in the controls
on the left here only shows death really
in a necrotic core and in this overlay
this composite image you you can't
really see the green fluorescence at
this resolution that I'm showing here on
the screen as the red stain that
indicates healthy functional
mitochondria really dominates the UV the
fluorescence here but what you can see
then is in compounds 1 & 3 which were
known toxic compounds that when we treat
organoids with toxic compounds you in
some cases at the really high
concentrations which are on the left you
you almost completely obliterate the
spheroid that's form and so all you see
are just a few cells that are labeled
with green and or with with daffy as you
can see but as you move across the
plates to the right at slightly lower
concentrations you can see that the size
of the steroids that are there are now
slightly bigger they're still showing
toxicity in the sense that they're
smaller than the controls and you can
also see much more the green
fluorescence indicative of more general
set of toxicity and then as you move to
lower concentrations
you can see that you're moving out of
the concentration range if you will
where toxicity was detectable and so
here all you see again is the red
fluorescence from from the healthy
healthy functioning mitochondria and for
comparisons we have two compounds here
compounds 2 & 4 which were known not to
show any toxicity in this assay so yeah
so we also performed this the same drug
toxicity assay and analyzed it with with
a different cell staining kit but also
on the cx-7 so for this one we repeated
the ass exactly as I just described and
it was stained with the café's with the
sub event caspase-3 7 or agent which is
used to detect a Polock cells and we of
course understand these with dapping 2
to identify all nuclei and so what you
can see here on the top left is that in
controls you can readily detect the
necrotic core in the middle of these
steroids and when you look then at drug
treated samples you know what's
immediately obvious is that the size of
the spheroid is smaller there are many
more green or a pop topic cells that are
now detectable and so using the software
is sort of represented in the images on
the bottom here you can use the software
to do any number of different types of
measurements here - whether it's you're
looking at the diameter or the surface
area of the sphere roid or you can you
can actually even count all the
different green and blue fluorescence
and because it's a confocal you can sort
of take optical sections throughout the
entire tissue and so you can get a
really nice multi parametric readout of
the state of health of the spheroids
that that you're working with so I'd
like to switch gears a little bit now
and focus the rest of the talk just a
bit organoids which of course are
another 3d cell culture system that's
extremely interesting and may also have
great application in the drug discovery
process
and as I described earlier a defining
feature of organoids is that they are
formed from other pluripotent stem cells
or adult stem and progenitor cells and
so the cartoon that I'll take you
through next is based on using
pluripotent stem cells which of course
are other embryonic stem cells or iPS ES
so these pluripotent stem cells have the
capacity to differentiate into the three
primary germ layers from which all cells
in the body are derived and these are
the three layers and David talked a
little bit about this in his
presentation these are the end of them
the mesoderm and the ectoderm and each
of these lineages makes unique
contributions to the entire animal body
plant for example the definitive end the
derm gives rise to the gastrointestinal
tract or le the epithelium of
gastrointestinal tract as well as many
of the organs that sort of form during
development from budding off this region
such as the liver and belong in the
pancreas and some others the mesoderm
gives rise to probably the bulk of the
tissue in the body as it gives rise to
all the muscle and and bone and such and
I just highlighted a couple of here for
some reasons I'll come back to in a
minute that the mesoderm is also the
source of kidneys and the heart the
ectoderm is sort of gives rise to two
major parts the ectoderm gives rise to
the epidermis by which of course forms
your skin but it also gives rise to the
central nervous system and so over the
past few decades researchers have really
identified many of the extracellular
signals in in some cases the
combinations of extracellular signals
that promote the formation of these
different cell types and so more
recently there's a lot of publications
of protocols that are usually based on
these developmental signaling programs
that have been shown to successfully
start with PSCs to generate organoids
that are representative of many
different types of organs such as all
the ones that i've shown here on the
screen and although it's not on the
screen i haven't shown it here in this
cartoon several labs have also very
successfully generated organoids
such as intestinal and liver organoids
from adult stem cells that were isolated
from adult tissue biopsies or resections
and a main advantage of these systems is
that the starting cells are already
restricted in the types of cells they
can become and so they can differentiate
oftentimes into a more mature phenotype
and exhibit better functionality than is
typically achieved with PSC derived
organoids
and I'll talk a little bit more about
this when I give an example from the
literature and just a few slides from
now the other thing that I'd like to
point is that this of course is not a
complete list of all the published
organoid systems there are a number of
others and in some cases there are
multiple different approaches one can
take to get to the same end end point
and these probably vary in some degree
based on their efficiency and the
complexity of the different cell types
that you end with and so I just want to
highlight a couple of review papers here
on the bottom of the screen for anyone
who's listening who want to learn more
about this these are two really nice
really comprehensive review system
review papers where you can read up a
whole lot more on the variety of
different PFC and also adult stem cell
derived organoids systems so over the
next few slides which are really just my
last few slides one of the things I want
to briefly highlight is just that
there's a whole lot of different
interesting papers that now utilize
organoids and are working on really
refining the protocols and and really
pushing this technology forward and so
all this slide is really meant to show
here is just a few magazine clippings to
highlight a few what I think of as some
of the landmark papers that have been
published to successfully develop
different types of PSC derived organoids
such as the intestinal models as well as
different neural models where
researchers have been able to generate
organized systems that recapitulate the
cell complexity
of different regions of the brain so the
two examples shown here are sort of the
the forebrain or the cerebral organoids
and as well as the midbrain like
organize which is where you find most of
the dopaminergic type neurons that David
talked about earlier as well so many
labs have now been really successful and
not only reproducing these protocols but
as I said they're really continuing to
push these fields forward and really
advance these these fields and making
the PSC durai's organize more and more
mature and getting them as close as they
can to to adult-like organoids adore
adult-like organs and the reason I say
this is that one of the key limitations
often seems to be the level of maturity
that these orgonites result in and so
often they retain a certain amount of
fetal or perhaps neonatal phenotype and
so you know that there is certainly a
lot of concerted effort in trying to to
make these more mature so a commonly
cited example of PSC derived organoids
are the intestinal organized which of
course develop with all the different
epithelial cell types that are normally
present in the human intestinal
epithelium and so the paper that I
clipped here is really it's a great
study that demonstrates how PSC derived
intestinal orgonites can be used to
recreate a key feature of Clostridium
difficile infection or C diff infection
if you will which is the disruption of
the intestinal epithelial barrier
function and so this paper is a nice
sort of it's a host-pathogen kind of
disease model and so as you may know C
this bacteria causes a very serious
infection and it's often and it's
generally implicated in about 14,000
deaths annually and is usually
contracted by patients who are already
in the hospital for other issues and so
these infections often disrupt the
integrity of the goddess Athena and can
cause severe diarrhea and lethal toxic
megacolon
so this infection also tends to be very
recalcitrant to antibiotic treatment and
existing 2d cell culture models do not
accurately recapitulate this disease in
a dish so there's of course a very
strong limitation there in the ability
to screen for new effective drugs to
treat these infections and so what the
research is in this paper were able to
do then so that they were able to
demonstrate that in a dish intestinal
organized form a lumen that also has a
very good para cellular barrier that
effectively prevents stuff from sort of
leaking from the lumen and out through
the organoid and they showed this by
directly injecting a 4 kilo dalton
fluorescent dextran directly into the
lumen and then just monitoring the
retention of the fluorescent molecules
in the organoid and so if you look in
part a of this figure the the top panel
is is the fluorescent images of this
assay where short immediately after
injection at 0 hours this is the level
of fluorescence that that you can see
from the injected dextran and there's a
pretty good retention of the ameno
fluorescence over the 12 and 18 hours
that this assay was designed for and so
what the researchers were able to do
then was they repeated this assay where
they injected either a bolus of viable
seed it or they could even get the same
result simply by injecting individually
the two toxins that seed if bacteria is
known to secrete and that are that form
a major part of the reason why this
bacteria causes such problems and so
what you can see here then is that over
the same timeframe the toxin a which is
the middle row panels and toxin B which
is the bottom row panels there's
certainly 4 K and in the case of toxin
egg there's a dramatic loss in the
amount of fluorescent or fluorescence
being detected in the lumen of these
organize and to a lesser extent toxin B
also work but just wasn't as severe as
Aang
and what this underscored of course what
is that the two different toxins
actually contribute to the to the
infection or to the pathology of the
issue in different ways and so the
authors were able to go on and describe
some of these contributions that these
toxins make or at least propose the
mechanisms of them and this seems to be
a pretty good agreement with the the
existing information about these toxins
that that's in the primary literature
and so really my take-home message from
this study that I want you to remember
is that these researchers were able to
use their 3d model systems in a dish to
develop an assay that you cannot do in
2d and it's a functional assay that they
develop and they're now in a position
where if someone was interested I'm sure
somebody is it is to use this functional
assay to screen for more effective drugs
that may be able to use to treat these
these deadly infections and so similar
to to the slides that I just went
through I also want to spend a few
minutes talking about sort of a case
study if you will of adult stem cell
derived organoids and so there are fewer
these are fewer in number than the PSC
derived organized protocols and probably
for obvious reasons but these again are
a couple of really important papers I
think that that help describe how to
make or isolate adult stem cells and
form these organoid systems in a dish
starting with adult stem cells and so
these of course had to be isolated from
tissue biopsies or resections and so a
couple of the clippings that I've shown
here are with respect to making adult
colon organoids or rectal organoids or
as well as organoids derive from cells
isolated from adult human liver and so
lastly I'm just going to give a brief
snapshot of how these organized
can be applied to disease model
and drug discovery so the papers that
I'm showing here develop the model for
studying cystic fibrosis and so cystic
fibrosis is a disease that's caused by
many different mutations that occur in a
transmembrane conductance transporter
protein called CFTR and this CFTR is
expressed in many different epithelia
but perhaps most notably as it relates
to the cystic fibrosis these would
include the lung epithelia the colon and
rectum epithelia and i believe it's also
expressed fairly prominently in the
biliary epithelial in the liver as well
and so these two sister studies that I
have up here on the screen both come
from the Beekman lab and they describe
the development of an assay where they
could successfully distinguish between
normal and cystic fibrosis or CF patient
derived rectal organoids
simply by treating the organized with a
compound called foreskin which is a
cyclic AMP II inducer and so what this
does in healthy control organoids
that porcelain induces the secretion of
fluid into the lumen of the organoids
which causes them to swell and so if you
look at these images on the right sort
of in the in the left column on the
bottom we're under control and WT WT
this is what the adult organized the
adult rectal organized look like after
treatment with forskolin where they slow
in to ask uptake their size and the
three panels above these controls or
above the wild-type are organoids that
were derived from patients that had
different mutations in the CFTR gene and
what you can see with these is that they
are far more recalcitrant or basically
they do not undergo any swelling upon
treatment with this horse one protein
and so immediately they had an assay now
where you can distinguish between like I
said healthy or diseased organized
and I would like to pointed that on the
labels on the far right the F 508 del
and the others this is just nominal
Eicher for some of the different
mutations that were present in the
patients from which these organized were
derived and the F 508 del is a amino
acid deletion but I think is the most
prominently associated mutation with
with this disease and so the right
column then is the result of what where
the authors were able to test several
different drugs and in this case that
this picture just shows two different
drugs that were at the time at least in
clinical trials and what they found was
if they treated the patient derive
organoids that showed no swelling in the
controls and the on treated sample if
they then treated them with these
different clinical trial drugs they can
rescue significantly the swelling
phenotype suggesting that they you know
this was a positive result for for the
drugs in terms of being something that
may have therapeutic potential and what
was then also quite remarkable was that
this information all correlated
extremely well with the clinical with
the actual clinical trial data that the
authors had access to so again this is
another really great proof of principle
study demonstrating that not only can
organize be used to screen for new drugs
but this technology could also be used
in conjunction with genetics in order to
stratify the spectrum of disease
subtypes and may one day be used for
personal toxicology to identify more
effective treatments especially in cases
where multiple treatments multiple
options for treatments make this and
there's some confusion over which
treatment is best tailored to to the
particular individual
and so with that I just like to go
through through this last slide so
hopefully you found some of this sort of
review like type information somewhat
interesting and before I finish I just
wanted to make a couple of additional
comments in the sense that although
these 3d model systems have come a long
way and are really exciting and hold a
lot of promise I think it's still a
little bit early to think of them as a
straight-up substitute for 2d models and
so what I'd like to stress is that there
are still a number of different issues
that I think is important for for those
of you in the audience for example who
may be thinking about currently using
these systems or are currently using
these systems and so some of the things
I'd like to point out or to remind
people that they need to consider when
they're using these systems is that
these generate visitor but there are
inconsistencies still in generating the
organizers and what I mean by this is
that organized after going through the
protocol they often comprised of
different sizes of different cell
populations and so by having variable
numbers of different cell types within
the organize it makes it a little
difficult to compare organize to
organize for example and so there
there's still a lot of effort going into
further refining these protocols to try
and make these more consistent and some
of this may come down to you know
applying a certain level of
bioengineering our corporation of things
like designer matrices which would sort
of substitute or overcome some of the
limitations of using ECM or tumor derive
ECM like substances such as major
geologists for example these designer
matrices are purely synthetic and
tunable and they can be impregnated with
with peptides where you can maybe more
accurately generate what the ECM looks
like in vivo for the cell or the
organized type that that you're
interested in
and so kind of the extension from this
then is that since there are multiple
cell populations within these organize
this can really complicate data
interpretation since if your setup is to
do more biochemical type analyses and if
you're actually interested in
understanding out of the biology or if
you're looking at mechanisms of action
for example it can be very difficult to
know what drug or what cell type your
drug treatment is actually affecting and
so some of the ways around this in the
future may be to to lean a little more
heavily on incorporating cell labeling
or cell tracing components to to your
organized so that you can then you know
insert them into a more high content
type analysis where you can look at all
the different cell types simultaneously
but distinguish the effects that you may
be seeing to a given cell type and the
last point that I'd like to just bring
up is that it's so important to remember
that these things are not in a normal
micro environment and oftentimes they
also lack vasculature and so although a
lot of the protocols do incorporate the
use of ECM proxies such as designer
matrices or or gel tracks and these
sorts of things it is still a proxy and
so it is still not exactly the same as
the normal micro environment and in
particular most of the published
protocols do not straight-up develop
their own vasculature but there may be a
couple of exceptions to that but there
are also some efforts where people are
incorporating a vascular component into
their protocol in order to kind of
overcome this limitation and perhaps in
the future using or coupling these
organized systems with with more
advanced technologies such as micro
fluidics
might be another way to to try and
reduce this this limitation so with that
I'd like to thank everyone who stayed
around and listened or knew people who
joined for the for this short talk I
think there is a question and answer
period
coming up at some point in the
not-too-distant future but in the
meantime if there are any other
questions you have feel free to email me
and I will do my best to get back to you
thank you thank you dr. Piper and dr.
Kennedy for your presentations so a
quick reminder for our audience on how
to submit questions simply type them in
the Q&A box found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window dr. Piper and
dr. Kennedy will answer as many
questions as time permits and the first
question from the audience is for both
speakers and it is what role do you see
stem cells and/or 3d models playing and
drug discovery in the future dr. Kennedy
would you like to go first sure I think
it would it go so I think there's still
a lot of promise in using IPS ES and
stem cells in the drug discovery process
I think the ability to scale these cells
and certainly generate lines from a wide
variety of different genetic backgrounds
are all clear advantages that existing
platforms may not offer and certainly in
the case of 3d models I think that these
you know there does seem to be certainly
a building of evidence that really
suggests that these the increased
complexity of these systems really leads
to these cells being able to better
predict whether a drug is toxic and and
they might even be more useful for doing
things like studies of efficacy that
existing 2d models for example don't
address necessarily very well so I think
there is definitely a future there I
think there is still some development
that needs to happen in order to develop
these systems into formats that lower
the activation energy of entry if you
will so that you know they can fit
seamlessly into existing workflows so I
think part of that might be the
limitation right now as well but but I
think that there's a very bright future
for these systems in
process that's a piper yeah you know I
think as we continue to move forward in
the drug discovery process you know IPSC
is offer an ability to generate cells
that are ordinarily not available
certainly to examine the biology or
pathology of disease in human neurons is
a real challenge so first of all being
able to generate specific cell types
that are that are representative of
human biology I think will be of great
importance it mean it's happening
already but as Mark said scale continues
to require some improvements to drive
that towards I think larger screening
applications and I think the screening
applications well we often think about
efficacy or safety
I think they'll also be used potentially
for target identification and validation
and I think the next obvious pieces to
combine the ability to use IPS C is the
ability to generate isogenic pairs with
some of the 3d modeling that Mark just
spoke about so that you can create in
vitro models that are much more
indicative of what may be happening in a
tissue if not an organ if not a human
being so this will take some time but
certainly I think it will support more
translatable and predictable models that
will help us reduce the development time
associated with therapy development
thank you both for that this next one is
for you dr. Piper is this human episomal
IPS seek as nine lines available for
purchase it is available as a as a
customized product we don't have it in
our catalog per se we use it on my teams
and people have requested it we do
provide custom services as part of our
organizational functions so anyone
that's interested can reach out to the
email shown here on the
mean discovery services at thermo Fisher
calm to inquire about that dr. Piper
will Chris Burke as non-working
non-dividing cells yeah so you can get
double-stranded breaks in non-dividing
cells however they typically are reduced
to non homology and joining repair I
don't think that we typically see
homology directed repair in non-dividing
cells now that said there have been
reports of using other repair mechanisms
so I believe Juan Carlos Belmont A's lab
has shown that you can get homology
independent targeted integration that
leverages the non-homologous end joining
pathway I'm not sure what kind of
efficiencies can be expected there but
again I think you know continued
technology development rule will
certainly allow for those sorts of
manipulations this next one is for
YouTube at dr. Piper do you have a
special media for circulating tumor
cells CPCs from melanoma patients you
know I'm afraid that we don't we do have
a very significant offering of basal
media and supplements that can be used
for any different cell types I think
some of our epithelial media's might be
might be used we certainly also have a
large number of media's that support
amount of plan Excel so it may depend on
the type and nature of the CTCs
it's not my area of domain expertise but
I'm not certain that they can all be
characterized identically so I think
there may be some patients specific
pieces that need to be understood and
addressed so you don't have a
specialized system for that but
certainly have a lot of the parts that
could be put together for specific
applications this next one
for you dr. Kennedy do you think that 3d
cultures could be utilized to build
tonic toxicity dosing models versus
acute talks of a labelled today it's a
good question I think that it would be
very difficult to do with with an
organized model depending on the type of
model you're looking for so for example
if you're looking for a liver model or a
liver organoid model I should say I
don't know that there's a robust enough
process or protocol defined to be able
to do that however I think spheroids
might be a little more applicable here
using primary kepada sites for example
one of the key advantages of using a pal
sites or primary cells in in three
cultures is that there's a major
increase in the in the lifespan of these
cells so typically in in 2d culture for
example primary hepatocyte might might
only survive for four to five days under
normal conditions somewhere in that area
anyway so certainly you're not able to
do any long-term or chronic dosing with
that kind of format I know there are
some improvements to that there are some
media supplements such as the hep extend
supplement that I believe is a catalog
product at thermo Fisher and with that
you can extend the lifespan of 2d
cultures but getting to 3d you know
people have repeatedly shown and we've
seen this ourselves as well is that it
becomes putting primary hepatocyte into
3d allow them to instead of growing for
four or five or six days it's much
easier to take them out for three weeks
maybe even four weeks so I think in in
terms of using steroids there are
certainly an opportunity to or an
ability to do a chronic type of dosing
assay currently this next mystery you
for dr. Piper where within the workflow
is typically the most challenging
and it's a two-parter so let me know if
you need to repeat the second part do
you have any tips and tricks to help
increase the likelihood of success in
building IPS c-drive disease model yeah
sure so you know in our hands I think
the most challenging part really is
generating the single cell clones so you
know my my very strong tip there would
be to test the ability to use stem flex
media with your cells if you don't have
a fax order you should be able to do
single cell dilution plating and still
drop you know one or less than one cell
per well you won't you know without a
fax sorter you won't be able to be sure
that you're not dropping a clump but
that is a significant time-saver for us
and takes out a lot of the tedium and
removes a great deal of the
unpredictable nature certainly delivery
is very important and I think if you
want to use patient derived lines using
the cast 9 nucleus protein pre complexed
with ivt guide RNAs is a very good way
to approach getting the tools in to get
good delivery and good editing
efficiencies if it's possible to insert
a mutation certainly we're demonstrating
that the stable cast 9 line has been
very effective but either of those
methods should work very well it looks
like we have time for one more question
and it is for you dr. Kennedy do you
think that 3d models are bitter or more
predictive and what about the cost yeah
so that's that's that's a great question
I was in some ways I was waiting to hear
that one so I think that there's really
a burden of evidence in the literature
right now that at least in some
capacities I think 3d models can show
better productivity there aren't a lot
of least that I'm aware of not a lot of
core facilities that are just straight
up incorporating these into their assays
I think there's still a lot of people
who are evaluating it for them
in house apart from what you find in the
basic literature or in the primary
literature but but I think that you know
depending on what your readout is I
think or what your metrics are I think
that 3d models are showing better
productivity yes with respect to the
cost that's still a challenging one
because some of these are time consuming
some of them require specialty plastics
it's in some way a little unclear how
they may fit directly into existing
workflows and if you're using a service
company for example that may be
providing these I know from what I've
been hearing these can be quite
expensive and so I think people who are
exploring this are still doing it in
somewhat limited capacity and so I don't
hesitate to try and put any particular
or any specific type of associated value
on it but it but I would say it's still
a little bit of a costly endeavor
depending on the scale at which you are
looking to to use these models in I
would like to once again thank dr. Piper
and dr. Kennedy for their presentations
if you have any final comments know just
thanks again to the participants for
joining us today and we wish you the
best in your own research and didle for
me thanks everyone for taking the time
to join us and I really hope some of
what you heard today was very useful and
will help you with your own research
endeavors thanks again to you both I'd
also like to thank the audience for
joining us today
and for their interesting questions
since we did not have time for today
we'll be answered after the presentation
we would like to thank our sponsors
Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on-demand
through November 2017 lab routes will
alert you via email when it's available
available for replay and we encourage
you to share that you know with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye
you